- [Instructor] What we are
going to do in this video
is discuss the United States Senate.
We're gonna focus not only areas
where the Senate has special influence,
where the House of
Representatives does not,
but we'll also focus on
how the Senate actually conducts business.
As we'll see the processes
and the rules that the Senate uses,
makes it more difficult
for simple majority
to do what they want.
So in terms of special influence,
only the Senate, not the
House of Representatives,
is involved in ratifying treaties.
The executive, the President,
they can negotiate a treaty
but it does not become effective binding
from a United States point of view
until it is ratified by
the United States Senate,
and it has to be ratified
by a 2/3 super majority.
This is one of the
reasons why it is viewed
that the Senate has more
influence on foreign relations
than the House of Representatives.
The other area that the Senate is involved
is in confirming appointments.
These could be appointments
to the President's cabinet.
These could also be
judiciary appointments.
It could be to lower federal courts
or to the United States Supreme Court.
The House of Representatives
once again is not involved.
But to appreciate just how things
go through the Senate,
whether we're talking about appointments
or even if we're talking
about general legislation,
let's remind ourselves
the overall process.
So let's just say that this
is a piece of legislation,
right over here.
It could have been drafted
by a staffer for a senator,
maybe with help from some constituents
or from some special interest groups
and maybe some lobbyist,
and it will be introduced to
an appropriate committee by
a senator or by a group of senators.
For example, if this legislation
is about the Armed Services,
it would go to the Armed
Services Committee.
The committee could decide
to have some hearings
around the legislation.
Maybe they bring in the
Secretary of Defense.
Maybe they bring in some military leaders.
And ask them questions about their views
about whether the legislation
is a good idea or not,
or they just want general context.
Then, they might also have some debate.
Then they might decide
to vote
on that legislation.
If that vote passes,
if they get a majority in that committee,
then it will go to the Senate
floor.
Before we even talk about what happens
on the floor of the Senate,
because that's where things
get really interesting,
it's important to point out
that even within committee,
the leadership has a lot of influence
and the leadership is generally controlled
by the majority party.
Because the leadership might decide
that hey you know what, they're
not interested in this bill,
so instead of going
through this process here,
they might just decide to table the bill
which kind of just puts it into a limbo.
But let's talk about the reality
where it does get voted on.
It does get a majority and
it goes to the Senate floor.
What's going to happen
next in the Senate floor
is a debate
over that bill, and I'm
writing debate in caps
because the Senate is
famous for its debates.
The whole idea of ending a
debate so that you can vote
is critical inside of the Senate.
Once you get to the vote,
if we're talking about a
general piece of legislation,
if we're talking about an appointment,
then you just need a simple majority.
So you just need 51 votes to pass.
Some of you might say, hold on a second,
I've always heard that at the Senate,
in order to do anything,
so need a super majority.
You might have heard the 60 vote number.
The reason why you hear
that is because many times
the folks who do not wanna have a vote
especially if they think that the vote
is going to go against them,
that one senator or it
could be a group of senators
that say, hey, I want
to keep debating on it,
and this protracted debate
is known as a filibuster,
which is a very strange word.
It was originally in reference to pirates
but it came to mean folks
who were trying to hold up
to the legislation process.
Its become a mechanism by which
the folks who don't want the vote,
who might be against the bill,
who might be in the minority,
they might not have enough
votes to defeat the bill
might still try to hold things up.
The reason why you heard about 60 votes
is because generally speaking,
that is a how you stop a filibuster.
If you wanna stop a filibuster,
you need to do something called cloture.
Or another way of thinking about it is
closure of the debate so
that you can get to a vote.
The reason why you hear 60 votes
is for general legislation,
you need 60 votes in
order to have cloture.
So even though you only need 51 votes
for the legislation to
pass once you vote on it,
to even get to that
point, you need 60 votes.
This is why you hear
that for a legislation
to actually get through the Senate,
you need the 60 votes.
There is an exception to this.
That exception is around appointments.
Prior to 2013,
in order to have cloture
for an appointment,
you also needed 60 votes.
But in 2013, it was decided that
for non-Supreme Court
appointments, you only needed 51
votes for
cloture.
Then in 2017, this was extended also
to Supreme Court appointments.
Now for appointments,
you only need 51 votes
for a cloture to end a filibuster.
And of course you only need
51 votes for the confirmation,
so functionally, you just
need A simple majority now
in the Senate for confirmations.
But legislation, you need 60 votes.
And of course for things like treaties,
you need a 2/3 super majority
to convict someone in an
impeachment, say the President,
you need 2/3 super majority.
And like the House,
if we're talking about
overriding a presidential veto
or amending the constitution,
you need a 2/3 majority.
What I've just talked
about, it isn't extensive,
it isn't exhaustive of all of
the processes in the Senate.
But hopefully, it gives
you appreciation of,
one, areas where the Senate
has special influence,
and also how the rules and
processes of the Senate
can be leveraged by
either majority parties
or minority parties in
order to get things done.
And how in the Senate,
it is harder for a simple majority
to do whatever they want.